you go online and you check out Jamie  Lee Curtis you can see the wonderful  things that they're saying about here  but there's always one thing that really  pisses me off when they say that she was  a supporting actress in the movie True  Lies because she was not supporting she  was the female lead she was the star I  was the supporting part in the movie  originally they were going to put my  name above the title it was Arnold's  idea Arnold felt that I should be up  there with him which was not part of my  contract I think that says more about  who Arnold Schwarzenegger is a man whose  life has been defined by that genre  allowing me to be there up beside him